KL Marx wrote that religion is the sigh
of the oppressed creature the heart of a
heartless world and the soul of a
soulless condition it is the Opium of
the people as the famous phrase goes do
you think he has a point no I hate that
quote I absolutely hate it I despise
this sort of Reddit internet atheist
activism for the simple reason that I
know many people who in finding Faith
have become objectively better human
beings yeah they start living
consciously they take morality seriously
they try we we all fail to be moral good
people so this sneering that these
midwit these marginally intelligent
people have towards religious people now
lots of religious people use religion to
rationalize their bad behavior or uh you
know sinful or ego so and so forth that
exists that's true but to say that it
never helps anyone and it's universally
the see Marx was talking about a period
I mean I'll defend his quote when his
argument was you know the masses are
being starved and oppressed but they're
promised you don't worry you'll have
riches in heaven so you should kind of
like let yourself be pushed around now
and this is kind of this BS bargain that
the people are being given so that was I
think the point he was making it's not
it certainly doesn't apply uh um
nowadays um I I I'm close to the family
in the midwest they're good Christian
people I remember very specifically this
guy shout out to him Sean shered I went
to college with him uh David Lucas um
and have you checked out the comedy
Mothership great great Club where is it
Austin um Willie Nelson and I you know I
was 17 18 freshman year uh and I was
reading all this criticism of the Bible
and I was like look this is in there
look at this in there and he put his
hand on my shoulder and he says Michael
there's nothing you're going to tell me
that's going to make me lose my faith
and that was a very uh self-aware and
profound thing to say as I've gotten
older and I lots of religious people
there's no part of me that um thinks
they're wrong or they should be mocked
it's
like it also reminds me of when people
sneer at uh addicts and recover
they're like alcoholism is a disease
it's a choice it's like wait a minute
you don't know what it's like to have
your entire life ruined by drugs or
alcohol and if you have to tell yourself
you know I have this disease and blah
blah blah and that keeps you from
drinking and now you're a moral
upstanding person who's reliable and and
takes responsible for their actions I I
I don't see the harm at all so I I think
this kind of activist atheism is uh
cheap I I don't agree with it whatsoever
and I I do not like that quote at all uh
but otherwise big fan of marks I mean
it's I I think there's a fan of mine I
forget who it was apologies he had this
great quote he goes the G and this is me
talking he goes the games people play to
to feel smarter than others is
depressing and annoying and I think this
kind of Fedora internet atheism is a
good example because here's the other
thing if you've proven that someone else
is stupid that doesn't mean you're smart
you could both be stupid mhm so congrats
you prove someone else is stupid who
cares yeah and sneering inol forms yes
in general is just
not great that's one of the things I
block out people on social media
instantly you're not going to sneer at
me in my space you could sneer me all
you want in your space but I'm not
putting up to your crap I don't know you
Myspace great social network is that on
uh six that six six
Street a
well.com clang clang that's how Lex
comes
like aov's dog that was the sound before
you get to see spend 10 minutes waiting
for an
image of a lady
load one line at a
time